It mean that keeps you up at night is the real dream
You should be chasing but to chase that dream to find that dream to make that dream a reality
You need a strategy. Don't waste your time trying to live someone else's life, you know, don't be trapped by Dogma
focus in on your own strengths your own element what you have to offer if you
Really want to achieve something you'll find a way and if you don't you'll find excuses
The motivation watch it top 10 with believe nation. What's that belief nation at seven?
My one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level talent at something and I want you to find it embrace it
I make a difference using it
So let's get your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew in today's lessons from a man who went from being bullied as a child for being
overweight and nerdy to becoming a monk in India
To now having a goal to make wisdom go viral and being one of the most viewed people on the internet
He's Jay Shetty and here's my take on his top 10 rules a success vol 2
enjoy
Okay, let's kick things off with rule number one have a plan how many of you have a crazy
Dream or a crazy goal. I want you to write out in the comment section
What is your crazy dream the dream that keeps you up at night is the real dream
You should be chasing but to chase that dream to find that dream to make that dream a reality
You need a strategy why a dream without a plan is just a wish
Tony Robbins said that right a dream without a plan is just a wish
Right without a strategy without a guiding philosophy without guiding principles without actually creating a clear plan
I used to have this economics teacher and I want you to think back to school as well. Maybe you had one
I remember this economics teacher you walked in to the classroom
And the first thing that you wrought in the board, he didn't even tell us his name
We'd even know who he was and he turned up he went inside the classroom and he wrote on the board. He said
Failing to prepare is preparing to fail and all of us. Just burst how laughing this guy
I don't even told us his name yet. But on the board, he wrote failing to prepare is preparing to fail
And now when I look back at that and as I grew up and hopefully became a bit more mature than I was in high
School, I remember thinking about that statement I thinking how true is that? Then when you're not prepared for something you miss out on our
Unbelievable opportunities now, I'm not saying good things don't happen spontaneously
Sometimes things happen by chance
Randomly, etc with a reason but when you're prepared you can capitalize on things in a huge huge way rule number two
Live in your element play to your own element. Don't try and perform someone else's expertly
So in modern terminology or how would I say that is?
Don't waste your time Steve Jobs. Don't waste your time trying to live someone else's life, you know, don't be trapped by Dogma
Focus in on your own strengths your own element what you have to offer don't get lost in
Trying to become like someone else or pretend to be someone else
There's a beautiful one of my favorite quotes by Einstein and then Steve Jobs
against said if you judge a fish by its ability to climb a tree they'll spend its whole life believing that it's stupid and
Too many of us are fish trying to climb a tree
Too many of us a monkey's being taught how to swim too many of us are lions being taught to live like cats
We're not getting to live in our element
So my second piece of advice is live in that element that you've naturally been given don't try adopt another
You know, we've more got a special genius inside of us
It was Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs this conversation
Steve Wozniak looked Steve Wozniak for those who don't know is the tech guy behind Apple
He practically invented the technology and the software and everything
So Steve Wozniak looked at Steve Jobs and he says this is in Walter Isaacson's biography of Steve Jobs
Steve wasn't I wasn't yet looks at Steve Jobs and he says what do you even do?
He said you're not a coder. You're not a designer. You know, what a marketer and you're not an engineer
What do you even do? Imagine challenging Steve Jobs and Steve?
Jobs replies he says he says musicians play their instruments. I play the orchestra that
Is the most deep understanding of one's role in life and not getting lost in other people's identities
And perceptions of you Steve Jobs knew that he wasn't a marketer. He wasn't an engineer
He wasn't a coder so he hired all of those but he played the orchestra. He brought it all together and
That's when you when you find confidence in your own role. You won't be envious of anyone else rule number three
Don't let failure stop you during a research experiment a shark was placed into a large tank of water
And then some small fish were released into that tank as you would expect the shock quickly swam around the tank
What's the fish and then ended up eating all of them?
Then a strong piece of fiberglass was inserted into the tank
This would create a division between where the shark started and where the smaller fish started again the shock quickly attacked
but they stunned the shark went in straight into the fiberglass divider and
Stop it tried this several times again and again and again until it became tired and weakened
Meanwhile the fish on the other side of the divider carried on swimming peacefully after about an hour
The shark finally gave up
This experiment was repeated several dozen times over the next few weeks where the shark became less
Aggressive every single time it got to the point where the shark stopped trying to attack and eat the fish
that's who the fiberglass was then removed out of the tank and
To their amazement the shark still did not attack
the shark had been trained through habit that a fiberglass divider was there and that he would bounce off and
Therefore didn't even consider it at the same time the small fish freely swam wherever they wanted the moral of the story
Many of us are experiencing setbacks and failures in everyday life
Eventually, we get emotionally drained tired unmotivated and we stopped trying
Like the shark in the story
We believe that because we've been unsuccessful in the past
That that barrier still exists even for new ventures in other words
We continue to see a barrier in our heads that
Separates us from our dreams even though there is no real barrier between where we are
Where we want to go and remember this the teacher has failed more times than the student has even
rule number four my personal favorite believe in your mission Fred Smith was an undergraduate at Yale University in
1965 as part of his coursework. He wrote an economics paper
Exploring the transportation of goods in the United States
It's how things get delivered to you and me he found that shippers were transporting large
Packages and items either via truck or through passenger airplanes. He thought he had a more efficient method
He wrote a last-minute paper as you do about how a company
Transporting small items via airplane would be a much better business model because he was rushed
He never really got around to explaining in the paper how that company with one and he ended up getting a C the funny thing
Is he still didn't give up and in 1971. He actually launched the company
He was speaking about but within three years of founding the company
Federal Express as it was called was actually on the verge of bankruptcy
They were losing over a million a month that was because of rising fuel costs
competitors in the same market and at its zenith it was only worth about
$5,000 Smith even made a final pitch to General Dynamics hoping for more funding it was rejected
Most people at this point probably would have just shut down
Projection the great C losing a million a month
but Fred Smith had different ideas Smith actually ended up flying to Las Vegas that weekend with all of what the company had the
$5,000 the Monday morning after the company had
$32,000 thanks to his blackjack skills that money made it possible to cover fuel costs for just a few days more
Soon after the company was able to raise significant funds he went around to multiple places to find sponsors
investors people that believed in what he was trying to achieve as a service the amazing thing is that he was
Creating a company that we all know today. It's called FedEx it now operates in over
220 countries and has an new revenue of over
45 billion dollars the interesting lesson that we can learn here is that there were countless
Occasions in Fred Smith's life where he could have said, that's it. It's not working for me
He could have stopped when he got that C for the paper. He could have stopped when he was losing a million a month
He could have even stopped when he finally only had enough to just last a few more days
But he believed in his vision
He had believed he had
Conviction about his idea and the process and the service that he was creating and that's the lesson here if you really want to achieve
Something you'll find a way and if you don't you'll find excuses
Rule number five have a strong why I think Mark Zuckerberg said it brilliantly at Harvard
He was saying that finding your purpose isn't enough
You have to help other people find this and I know you're passionate about this whatever that definition is
But it has to lead everyone
So if I'm whether I meet a celebrity and entrepreneur or whether I meet somebody starting out, I'm always asking them this question
How can you use what you have to make a difference in the life of other people?
Yeah, because if you start there everything else will work out but if you're starting from the point of what am I gonna get?
then you're always gonna feel disconnected and I see that I see people
Who live like that and feel pain in their lives every day? I see that it's not like some
Conceptual philosophy we see it. I see people who are only in it for themselves and they feel disconnected
dissatisfied every single day and
then you see the other extreme where people are just trying to give too much more than they even have themselves and they also feel
Disconnected and again, nothing at all. Nothing at all. Right so we know it again
attachment and aversion two sides of the same coin
Mm-hmm. So we want to be in that dynamic balance of growth but always to give yeah
So I always think how can I go three steps deeper so that I can move three steps forward
So I can give three times as much
Right, it's all that's always my mentality. How do I go deeper to go more forward to give more?
Yeah
And if I can get those three in action for that reason see it's what about the reasoning?
You can do anything you like but it's why are you doing it worse?
rule number six train like underdogs
Now it's incredible that we root for underdogs. It's incredible that we want underdogs to win
Why because we're used to wanting our team to win we're used to wanting the best to win
We're used to wanting to associate ourselves with people who are successful, right?
We never go. Oh, yeah
I know someone who plays for that really bad team like we don't say that right we say things like oh
I know so many place without really good team. I know someone who was MVP
I know someone who's the son or the daughter of the MVP?
We try and associate or link ourselves to success and when we do that it in turn makes us feel more successful
It's one of the reasons why when your team wins you say we won, right?
You say we won but when someone asks you or how did your team do and if they lost that day you say they lost?
you rarely say we lost it's incredible how
psychologically, we distance ourselves from failure and we close and or like on ourselves to success but
The exception to that rule is the underdog we all get excited by underdogs. We all get motivated by underdogs we feel
Completely enamored by the story of the underdog prashant. Underdogs are just simple minded
They don't have expectations and don't have anything to prove to anybody and Prashant. You've just hit the nail on the head
That's the principle. I'm trying to get across
Actually, we should play like champions and train like underdogs
Why because the underdog works in a way not worrying about what anybody else thinks or believes?
That gives you an edge
It gives you a phenomenal advantage when you're actually worried about what will people say
when you're not concerned by am I going to fail am I'm going to look worse is what I'm doing not going to
Succeed as an underdog you don't let those things cloud your mind. You can focus in on the task at hand
See when we become successful even as underdogs if we've risen to success the biggest
Enemy of that success the biggest Achilles heel
The biggest thing that can trip us up is not me connecting to that feeling of an underdog
So no matter how much success you've achieved no matter where you are always remind yourself
the mindset of an underdog is the mindset that nurtures talent that nurtures success that
Harnesses your true potential rule seven go through hurdles
This man began singing and playing the guitar at aged four his parents didn't want him to watch too much television
He was banned from playing video games, but he had a lot of books about art
He didn't enjoy school and was even bullied at age 15 a year. Later
He decided to quit school and follow his dreams of making in the music industry
Now things didn't go as planned
He ended up homeless sleeping often on trains
Just to get by this lasted for around three years where he had nowhere to live
He spent multiple nights and days
Performing to small groups often without even eating to his surprise some of his tracks went viral on iTunes
Even reaching the number-two spot on the iTunes chart by the end of the year. His album had sold
800 and 1000 copies making it the eighth best-selling album of the year
His latest song was one of the most listened to worldwide
His name ed
Sheeran today, he's mentored by Elton John Paul. McCartney says that he's a fan
He's even written songs for Taylor Swift in one direction and many many more
Edie story teaches us that there's no such thing as an overnight success
He was so shocked and surprised when his album went viral online
But when you look at the struggle before that you see the pain he had to go through
Often we only view people's
success as what we see in their highlight reel and we forget what they actually
Had to go through to get to that stage and that's why the next time you see someone that you think is successful
Don't focus on what they're doing now
Focus on what they did to get them real number 8 grow your brand. What are the people not?
Understanding about video, okay
What are they not understanding about how powerful it is for their business their brand and ultimately their message to impact people
It's always that same question. What's the ROI on social media? Right? What's the ROI now?
The funny thing is your business work in service my business work in service literally lives off of social media
so there's obviously an ROI, but the problem is we live in a world where we want everything to be measurable and
There's a beautiful Einstein code that says not everything that counts can be counted and not everything that you can count counts
Right, and we live in this world where everything needs to be measured like, oh that video has a million views
How many cells did you get through that but it's like life doesn't work like that
There's a load of adverts and billboards on the street that the biggest brands pay for that don't convert into direct sales
Do you think that coca-cola looks at the billboard out there and goes how many people saw that advert today?
And how many people bought I look because of that advert. They don't have that number
It doesn't exist and they're one of the biggest brands in the world, but they still do it
So social media video is just a new billboard. Mm-hm and the biggest brands know
That the more you see it like I mean, this is funny
I saw this thread so a big billboard outside of my hotel
That has all the Jenners and the Kardashians wearing their Calvin's. Have you seen it?
I saw it straight away this morning. Then I swear on Instagram and then I swear everywhere
So already I've seen in three places now. I don't need women's Calvera underwear
But the point is that I've seen it in a million places. So anyone who's not using video hasn't understood
That more people are going to see video than anything else and notice that video is so much better than a billboard
You can say so much more, right? So for me, it's just a lack of seeing opportunity
There's a there's a great. I think this is a old tale. It's not true
But but it's told that when Nike first went to India
They went there and it's not Nike it's any any sneaker brand
It's its ass nice story and when they first went to India, they saw everyone was barefoot
So the first reporter came back and said or there's no market there because no one wears trainers
and then the second reporter went then he said
Oh, no one wears shoes. And then he came back and says we've got a huge market out there
Right and it's the way you see it that someone a sword no one wearing shoes. There's no mark here
But another presence what everyone not wearing shoes as a marketing
Right, and that's what video is that?
You can sit here and debate the ROI on video for as long as you want
The truth is every major brand has invested
In a front window that may know translate to direct sales or work or whatever it is, man
But it does you think every brand should be using video. Every brand should be using video rule number nine choose love
I'm almost 30 and I don't feel like I've accomplished anything in life
I made a promise to myself while I was a university that I would get a job that excites me every morning
But right now I'm afraid I'm not going in that direction
That note was written by a young person and when I read it my heart sank
I felt that way because I know so many people that are in that exact position
I remember when I decided to trade my nine-to-five for a
24-7 it was because I wanted to do something that was meaningful every day
I wanted to do something that was purposeful and fulfilling from the moment. I woke up to the moment
I went to sleep. The one thing. I didn't know before I started is how achievable that was
But also what it required when I transitioned from my nine-to-five or actually my 9:00 to 9:00 to her 24/7
I realized that I was going to have to work harder smarter and faster and that step was full of fear full of
Anxiety full of insecurities full of questions like what will happen if it doesn't work
What will people say should I just have stayed where I was I went through all of those emotions all at the same time
And then something came to me
I wrote down the various options that I had in life at the time and ever a word above them that I believe summarized the
Experience or the result of what?
I thought that would give me some of them said ego because I thought those career paths would give me a boost to my ego
Some said security because there were certain roles or jobs
I could take that would provide a certain level of financial security and then one path said the word love because I knew if I
Did that that I would love every moment even if it was truly
Challenging and sometimes really difficult to deal with and that's why I'm here today making this video speaking to all of you because I chose
The path that had the word love above it try that exercise. Try that activity out to try and
Differentiate the motive the intention behind what you're choosing and selecting in life
Now just because you choose the word love doesn't mean that everything's gonna be smooth sailing and are you going to be successful?
It's going to have its own ups and downs and that's why wherever you go with your heart
Take your head with you and rule number ten. The last one before some very special bonus Clips is make wisdom
Go viral, what's the impact that you want to have on the world?
I think you've you've said it so beautifully so many times and shared my vision
Which is wonderful and it's wonderful to know that we share the same thing. It's making wisdom. Go viral
There's an incredible study in 2017 that said the most
successful people in the world
healthy wealthy and wise
Choose education
over entertainment
The impact I want to have from the world is I want to transform and revolutionize the entertainment industry
So that it becomes educational without anyone knowing so it's still completely
Entertaining it's still like watching Netflix
But you're learning about human behavior the mind neuroscience and everything without even knowing you are to me
That's the greatest win that we can have for our society. How many people are going to quit watching Netflix?
I'm reading a book every night. I don't know
But if we can make that book come to life on Netflix that's going to change the world
Because that's what people are going to consume so for so long
Media has been used to numb people to to switch people off if we can use it to excite elevate enlighten people
Not by just not by like the cheesy way of like well
Let's follow someone through their journey of enlightenment or like that kind of stuff
I mean like really entertaining programming where you can learn by being entertained at the same time if I can do that
By changing the most powerful industry in the world. Then I will feel that I've had some some whatever an impact
Because that way I think we'll reach the world without having to get Iran to change their habits too much
my my thing is, how do we meet people where they are and
And really deliver a message and a powerful
expression of love and to me that's the highest form of compassion the highest form of empathy love and compassion is
To meet people where they already are rather than expecting them to change you
Now I've got two very special jay Shetty clips on how to one be resourceful and two don't underestimate the power of volume
But before that I want to know what did you learn from this video?
What's the single most important lesson that you're going to apply to your life your business somehow?
Leave it down the comments below when you write it down. It's much more likely that you're going to actually take action on it
So, let's see it in the comments. Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much. Love see you soon, and enjoy the bonus clips
So I quit my job comfy corporate job doing really well for myself and I'm trying to get into media
and so I'm
Writing to every big media company with before my videos and saying please give me a job
Like I'll come in like a video journalist salary
I was looking at salaries that like a quarter of what I made. I was like I don't care about the money
I want to make videos and I want to spread a message
I'm getting rejection email after rejection email saying Jay you never studied. Media Jay. You have no background
So I'm getting rejected by all the biggest companies Business Insider HuffPost The Economist wired. You name it I've got all emails and
Then I try and network with the editors of these magazines. So I find out where they are
I go to the events are trying to talk to them and they liked me. Hey, man, you're like 28 years old
Why do you want to do this? You make more money right now. Hang in the corporate world. Do it as a hobby
I remember running after one of our biggest news anchors in England called John snow and
He rides a biker in London, please
Like he's huge is on Channel four one of the biggest
Broadcasters for us her and so I've run off to him when he's on his bike and I'm like John
Please please stop and he stops. He's really kind. I said John. Can you please give me a job?
I'll just I don't want to get paid I'll just watch you and I because he creates these powerful documentaries
He's interviewed the best of the best like Mandela and all this time life-changing
Conversations and he goes to me he gives me a card and he goes Jay go get a masters and median and come back
I'm thinking oh, it's one two, three more years. Yeah, exactly
I'm gonna go back like Annie
So I came to a point where I literally had no other option than to start a YouTube channel
and
And my honest limiting belief at the time was that doesn't work for anyone and that's what I said to myself as well is not
Gonna work for anyone but I literally had exhausted. I think it's Thomas Edison who says when you feel you've exhausted every option
Remember you haven't and I'd come to that point where I felt I'd exhausted every option apart from starting a YouTube channel
So I launched the channel Jan 3rd, 2016 two years ago and it's doing pretty well. Have you ever seen someone successful or famous?
And thought I could do that better than them. So, what's the difference?
Why is it that they're out there achieving their goal while you're not able to see people?
Underestimate the value of volume the potential behind. How many doors are you ready to knock on?
How many toilets are you willing to send how many people are you willing to ask for help and ask for their guidance and stares?
We hardly achieve anything the first time we try the people that have made it it's on their tenth twenty a hundred
Sometimes thousand attempt, so don't underestimate the power of volume
Don't underestimate what's possible when you go out there and speak to everyone that you know
The most important work ever if you had to think of one word
That's most important to you or that sums you Apple so it would be like a little beacon
Table Ignatian if you want to know what the most important one word is for Tony Robbins, Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz. I have a very special secret video for you check the description for details